fue el cerebro detrás de la operación
Esperanza el general colombiano Pedro
Sánchez se involucró personalmente en la
búsqueda de cuatro niños perdidos en la
selva colombiana aún conserva las marcas
de la inofitalidad de la amazonía unos
200 hombres estuvieron bajo su mando
entre soldados y civiles nativos a pesar
de su formación militar Sánchez destacó
la combinación de la cultura ancestral
con la disciplina castrense para hallar
a los infantes en un momento en el cual
aplicamos la ciencia militar al conocer
esa espiritualidad que ellos manejan
hubo algo que encajó y que finalmente
condujo a encontrar estos cuatro menores
porque los indígenas tomaron ya
y en sus visiones orientaban diferentes
puntos a pesar de los riesgos que
suponía operar en una zona de tráfico de
drogas y armas un aspecto en particular
los alertó la actividad de grupos
guerrilleros Cuando ocurrió el accidente
había un cese bilateral el fuego con
esas disidencias pero en medio de la
búsqueda se rompió ese acuerdo porque
asesinaron ellos son mata indígenas
ellos Asesinan a los más vulnerables de
nuestro país y se rompió ese ese
bilateral y en una de las áreas donde se
rompió es en los departamentos que los
Estamos buscando
Sánchez quien también es padre se
mantiene al tanto de la evolución de los
menores ingresados en el hospital
Militar de Bogotá en un país donde el
estigma de la violencia pesa sobre los
uniformados este episodio marcó una
etapa inédita de colaboración entre
civiles y militares